en nuestras aventuras matemáticas
anteriores habíamos resuelto cosas como
x mas x x
como un pequeño repaso esto es igual a x
x x que es x al cuadrado más x x menos
que es menos x mas x x que es mas x y
luego menos 10 porque o podría decir que
por menos por lo que será igual a menos
y al cuadrado menos x mas x y esto se
simplificará como x al cuadrado menos y
al cuadrado
todo esto es un repaso aprendimos esto y
pensamos en factorizar diferencias de
cuadrados pensamos en esto cuando
aprendimos a multiplicar binomios y lo
que vamos a hacer ahora es esencialmente
lo mismo pero con expresiones un poco
más complicadas otra forma de expresar
lo que acabamos de hacer es que también
podríamos escribir algo como a más b
a menos ve a que será igual bueno va a
ser igual a cuadrada menos be cuadrada
la única diferencia entre lo que hice
aquí y lo que hice aquí es que en lugar
de una x escribí una y en lugar de una y
escribí una b a partir de esto veamos si
podemos resolver y luego combinar
términos semejantes si estoy
multiplicando estas dos expresiones
digamos que estoy multiplicando 35 x a
la cuarta potencia por 3 menos 5 x a la
cuarta potencia pausa este vídeo y trata
de resolverlo muy bien hay dos maneras
de abordarlo
podríamos abordarlo exactamente de la
manera en que lo hice aquí arriba pero
ya sabemos que cuando tenemos este
patrón donde tenemos algo más otro algo
multiplicado por el mismo algo menos el
otro algo bueno esto tendrá la forma de
este término al cuadrado menos este
término al cuadrado y recuerden la única
razón por la que estoy haciendo esto es
porque tengo un 13 aquí y aquí
y este 3 está desempeñando el papel de a
entonces déjenme escribir eso esta es
nuestra
y luego el 5x a la cuarta potencia está
jugando el papel del ave así que esta es
nuestra vez esto va a ser igual aa al
cuadrado menos b al cuadrado pero
nuestra es 3 entonces será igual a 3 al
cuadrado menos nuestro ave es 5x a la
cuarta potencia menos 5x a la cuarta
potencia al cuadrado ahora cómo se
simplifica todo esto bueno esto va a ser
igual a 3 al cuadrado es 9 y luego menos
5 x a la cuarta al cuadrado
veamos 5 al cuadrado es 25 y luego x a
la cuarta al cuadrado bueno esto va a
ser x a la 4 por 2 x a la octava
potencia otra forma de pensar en ello
son las propiedades de los exponentes
esto es lo mismo que 5 al cuadrado
x a la cuarta al cuadrado sí elevó algo
a un exponente y luego lo elevó a otro
exponente multiplicó los exponentes y
aquí lo tienes hagamos otro ejemplo
digamos que te pregunto cuánto estrés de
cuadrada más 2 a la quinta potencia por
3 de cuadrada menos 2 a la quinta pausa
este vídeo y trata de resolverlo bueno
vamos a hacerlo de la misma manera por
supuesto siempre puedes intentar
desarrollarlo como lo hicimos
originalmente pero podríamos reconocer
aquí que tengo una a más una vez por la
a menos la ve de modo que esto va a ser
igual a nuestra a cuadrada entonces
cuánto estrés de cuadrada al cuadrado
bueno esto va a ser igual a 9 ya a la
cuarta y cuanto éstos ya la quinta
potencia al cuadrado bueno 2 al cuadrado
es igual a 4 y a la quinta al cuadrado
es ya las 5 por 2 es igual a la décima
potencia y no se puede simplificar más
no puedo combinar términos semejantes
así que hemos terminado